[Music]
lex luthor fried the circuits bringing
his creature to life there's not enough
charge to wake the box
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Justice League
video there were a bunch of big
headlines making the rounds this morning
you probably saw so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Easter
eggs will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do after the Justice League
Snider cut if it's as successful as it
seems like it's going to be for HBO max
what do you want their next big project
to be so just starting with number 5 if
you didn't see the news this morning the
big thing is that ray Fisher the actor
who plays cyborg posted another very
dramatic statement about working on the
Justice League theatrical cut with Joss
Whedon he also references Geoff Johns
and John Berg who were the studio
producers at that time working on all
the DC movies so this is the statement
that he made and this is actually a
pretty big deal he says Joss Whedon's
onset treatment of the cast and crew of
Justice League was gross abusive
unprofessional and completely
unacceptable he was enabled in many ways
by Geoff Johns and John Berg
accountability is greater than
entertainment this is also in addition
to the video that he posted of himself
from Comic Con 2017 a couple of days ago
saying that he'd like to retract the
statement that he was making in the
video from Comic Con 2017 and this was
happening at the Justice League panel so
this is the clip that he posted no I
think we're just about finished with
everything they've been briefed if
anything but yeah I mean Joss is a great
guy and Zac picked a good person to come
in and and clean up and finish up for
him as you can see it was him just
answering a fans question during the Q&A
portion of the panel about what it was
like working with Joss Whedon on the
movie after working with Zack Snyder he
gives a big thumbs-up saying that it was
pretty great Zack Snyder picked a great
person to take over for him when it
actually came to hiring Joss Whedon to
come do though the reshoots and take
over the movie from Zack Snyder I think
that he was instrumental in reaching out
to Joss Whedon but I think the studio is
also involved in that too but as you can
see during the panel there when he's
answering that fans question in front of
thousands of people and obviously making
all these public statements it's very
political answer because they were
trying to hype up the movie this was a
couple months before they released the
film studios have all kinds of PR stuff
built into actors contracts saying that
they're not going to try and torpedo the
movie
that they're promoting while they're on
the press tour that's why even if an
actor has a really bad experience on a
movie any movie it doesn't have to be a
DC movie it could be any movie anywhere
during the press tours usually you never
hear people saying stuff like this the
stuff that cyborg is posting to his
Twitter account right now usually you
only see major actors posting stuff that
big when they feel like they either have
nothing left to lose or something really
terrible happened or they don't mind
harming their relationship with the
studio the directors the producers that
they're taking shots at in their posts
so number four what does that all mean
what is he saying Joss Whedon did on the
set of Justice League that was so bad
well he's mostly trying to call him out
for being unprofessional to the cast and
crew to the point of being abusive
reading between the lines remember what
happened on that movie so Joss Whedon
was brought in to do extensive reshoots
ineffectively Frankenstein create a
whole different type of movie than what
Zack Snyder was originally planning in a
very very short amount of time so it was
already kind of an impossible situation
for everyone involved with that the
studio refusing to move the release date
to give them more time in my take on
this just assuming that actors tend to
be a little bit overdramatic is that
Joss Whedon just ran everyone at warp
speed through filming all those new
reshoot scenes and that's what led to
this scenario that ray Fisher is calling
abusive and unprofessional like not
giving the actors and crew more time to
prepare for each of their scenes blowing
through takes as quickly as possible
before moving on to the next scene not
giving them quite as much feedback as he
might give during a traditional movie
with a regular schedule really good
example I just posted a video of Hugh
Jackman breaking down all the Marvel
Wolverine movies and during that video
he tells the story about filming the
ending scene of the Logan movie his
final movie is Wolverine as far as we
know where Wolverine is dying in the
director james mangold spent a couple of
hours just filming these two to three
minutes of footage where he's in the
process of slowly dying because it was
such a huge moment for the character in
the end of a 17-year journey of Hugh
Jackman playing the character in real
life you know there was some types where
I was weeping and he goes yeah we're not
gonna use that but good for you
[Laughter]
he was glad I was like so they wanted to
get the scene right so they just took
way way extra time than they normally
would on a traditional movie and Hugh
Jackman just said that James Mangold
came to him and said sit here in the
moment of this scene and just take it
all in we'll just take as much time as
we need to get it right so clearly given
the schedule that they were on for the
Justice League reshoots the opposite is
what happened for all those actors which
is why I think that ray Fisher cyborg is
making all these really really big posts
number three the flip side of this an
actor on justice league making a bunch
of big statements like this would be
what Henry Cavill has been doing
remember a little while ago when all the
Justice League actors were posting about
releasing the Snyder cut it seemed like
everybody was in on it like all the
actors oh this is a big deal maybe they
really will release the Snyder cut and
then Henry Cavill was surprisingly the
only one who was not posting about any
of it at that time there were a couple
reasons for that there's a couple
reasons why he's never really gone off
in a big way about Snyder cut stuff
right after the movie came out he did
talk about coming back as Superman when
he was still promoting Mission
Impossible he still at the mustache he
posted a couple of videos to his social
media about doing future Superman movies
but the reason why he was so quiet about
it when the other actors were posting
about it one he was clearly still in
negotiations with the studio for a new
Superman contract for the crossover
movies that we just found out about that
he's supposed to appear in and still
trying to pitch them a new Man of Steel
Superman movie in had Henry Cavill
started posting all kinds of incendiary
statements it probably would have hurt
his chances of coming back before the
contracts had actually been signed in
the ink had dried but it's also probably
his management team behind the scenes
telling him to just chill on all that
stuff and be a little more diplomatic
like I said actors usually only start
posting big stuff like this when they
feel like they aren't going to be
working with certain Studios or
producers ever again
or they don't feel like they have
anything left to lose the thing about
this though is that the cyborg character
is supposed to show up during the flash
flashpoint movie so maybe cyborg has
already resigned a new contract to come
back for that we've been talking about
Michael Keaton Batman appearing during
that for the past week or two just
because it's such huge news Michael
Keaton coming back as Batman for the
flash movie in other future DC movie
this is so great but also buried within
that with a flash producer saying that
cyborg would have some sort of role
during the flash movie but number two as
for that Justice League Snyder cut
cyborg clip it's just a vision cyborg
has of the mother boxes Darkseid Green
Lantern in the Dark Side war thousands
of years ago that he's seeing when he
interfaces with the Kryptonian ship and
the mother box the whole idea is that he
was created by one of the mother boxes
so it's part of him he's fundamentally
linked to it and therefore knows
everything that the mother Box knows or
at least has access to all the
information that it holds the whole idea
with his character during the movie is
that he still doesn't understand
everything in back when they were still
doing multiple Justice League movies you
would have seen his character evolved to
learn to control his technology more
than the technology controlling him so
this wasn't supposed to be him
connecting to Darkseid or speaking to
him or anything like that it's just him
having a vision of Darkseid through the
mother box like in the other Snyder cut
trailer that Zack Snyder posted a little
while ago of Wonder Woman seeing
Darkseid that wasn't her speaking to
Darkseid or anything like that or heard
going back in time
it was just her seeing a picture of
Darkseid as far as we know they weren't
actually going to literally meet
Darkseid until the end of the movie but
the ending of the Snyder cut is going to
be very very different from the ending
of the theatrical cut but number one the
two characters in the Snyder cut that
are probably getting the most new scenes
are Superman and cyborg they were barely
in the theatrical cut which also might
be part of the reason why the cyborg
actor ray Fisher is making these posts
because he was kind of taken out of the
movie in the Joss Whedon cut there were
a ton of cyborg deleted scenes from the
Snyder cut that leaked online after the
movie came out you probably seen at
least a couple of them there's some
stuff that I add at the beginning of the
video there's a couple of trailer scenes
of him recreating some environments with
his new abilities and since the Snyder
cut is supposed to be over four hours
long I'm assuming that all that every
last speck of new footage for all the
characters is going back in they'll also
probably be a much bigger trailer for it
at the DC fan dome Comic Con panel Zack
Snyder is going to be there in some of
the cast I don't know if every one of
the cast members is participating so of
course I'll do videos for all the
footage that they drop so everyone just
post all your predictions in the
comments below and you can click here to
rewatch that Justice League Snyder cut
trailer video and
here to watch hugh jackman breakdown all
the Marvel Wolverine movies thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]